bonjour bienvenue dans ce
troisième épisode des gentes
dames pas l'air il nous
intéresse
roanne samedi d'un puissant du
16e siècle
j'ai nommé marguerite
d'autriche bref encore une femme
riche et noble
j'aimerais bien pouvoir vous
parler de femmes intéressante
qui ont vécu et moyenâgeuse
qui n'était pas issu de la
noblesse
mais c'est compliqué parce que
les sources sont pas très peur
dans le temps qui le suspectait
que je serai maire stéphane
bern de youtube
c'est parti pour un périple de
triche quand j'ai découvert que
la vie j'ai été impressionné
par deux choses
son habileté en politique et
rés sa vie amoureuse
désastreuse c'est un peu facile
d'avoir un carnage aussi
merdique
marguerite d'autriche et de
talent bordeaux il est donc le
10 janvier dernier 4 80
abruxelles et elle est la
petite-fille de charles le
téméraire mais côté pas
vraiment du côté des profs qui
je parlais pas dans le duc de
bourgogne à un moment donné du
coup sa mère c'est marguerite
de bourgogne et sans perte et
maximilien premier
ou peut-être pas mal de tête
à 3 ans marguerite est fiancée
et les dons directement envoyée
à la cour de france où se
trouve son succès avec l'om
% et futur roi de france charles
viii
comme il est en plus que l on va
attendre un peu avant de
débarquer
donc elle est aidée à la cour
de france tout se passe bien
jusqu'à ce qu'elle atteigne
l'âge de 11 ans que son mari la
république
qu'est-ce qui préfère exposer
à de bons côtés
marguerite d'autriche rentre
donc chez son père servez avec
la base et un premier mariage
par apple et c'est le déluge à
la fin de l'année 1496 elle
embarque pour l'espagne parce
que comme les relations avec la
france sont des puits son
mariage raté un peu tendu son
père décide de se rapprocher
des rois d'espagne elle épouse
donc à présent les gendarmes
ont été les clés du tour de
castille et d'aragon hélas le
grand amour ils sont heureux
pendant six mois
les comités de santé fragile
il meurt en 1797
et malgré tes parents
mais elle fait une fausse couche
elle rentre en effet enfants
ajoute-t-elle
encore une fois installé à la
faveur d'un temps déjà inscrit
mariée deux fois mieux
finalement
jamais deux sans trois son
troisième mari télécom dans
les temps forts et s'ils gardent
bien de savoir au bassin en
prestige mais ça serait bien
ils sont heureux de terminer
chaque fois la fête ensemble et
surtout chez les dames confier
la gestion des affaires du
duché de savoie
ceci lui permet de montrer un
certain talent politique est
fortement implantée sur le
petit écran car à l'encontre
du royaume de france donc elle
va orienter la politique du
savoir vert de la maison des
ados la maison
mais parmi 134 30 ans après le
mariage son mari meurt dans un
accident de chasse
et alors qu'elle était encore
enfant sans père encore une
fois il faut s'occuper ça
commence à être dur
elle fit édifier le monastère
de brou à la mémoire de son
mari et ensuite elle rentre chez
elle
elle a seulement 24 ans et
commence à saturer un peu le
parcours de son père et fait de
la mariée elle dit stop
et à partir de là elle se
consacre à d'autres activités
comme le mécénat et la
politique
dans sa course à malines elle
reçoit des écrivains comme
rennes des musiciens comme
quelqu'un de dépressif il
fallait beaucoup de commandes
d'atr il peut embarquer les
riches
après sans faille avec soin
d'éviter la pénurie comté
d'artois de faire de bourgogne
de chambre des deux macbook
par comparaison en catimini elle
reçoit un revenu de 20 minutes
plus tard mans
et partant dernier mariage elle
a 12 minutes séparant traces de
coups ont plu de batié de
rouerie de villarreal
au niveau politique en effet un
prophète a déjà récente des
pays-bas pour le compte de son
objectif sur le long terme qui a
la fibre elle met aussi en place
des alliances politiques
eneurope
souvent contre la france
passé par charles hamelin 540
milliards rappelle en 1519 au
moment de son accession au
trône chez les animaux la
retransmission de la couronne
impériale se fait par
élections donc pour gagner il
faut être clair et comme dans
le monde connaît tout le monde
elle a vite fait de transformer
chaleur charge car contraire
et de récupérer au passage la
gouvernante suède des pays-bas
en 1529 estimé que la paix des
dames qui règlent les conflits
entre françois 1er et charles
quint
elle représente alors charles
quint avec marie luxembourg
cette coutume
et louise de savoie
représentant sous françois 1er
évitez aussi les connaisseurs
de marguerite que ce que
l'acteur de philibert de savoie
avant de devenir la mer de
france 3
il étend le champ finalement un
art de la gangrène à 1530
après-midi bien remplie et pour
finir mal que d'autres sont
décrits comme de 2009 porte au
nez une forcenée
alors qu'on mérite
qui en plus d'être une bête
politique ce que je crois elle
ne veut pas dire grand-chose
tout seul mais montrant brooks a
connu l'infortuné l'infortuné
cal est restée forte si vous
êtes curieux ont trop sur
gallica qu'une notice
explicative sur ces deux villes
cependant comprendre les
différents plans c'est que le
mélange des cultures
à dans deux semaines donc pour
la dernière chance de la
baguette de l'été
et n'oubliez pas
or tous les goûts pour tous les
sports tous les